Ich bin Melon die Maschine, ich möchte euer Freund sein, Freund, Freund, Freund, ha ha ha, Freunde haben Spaß, München, gebt euch auf die wir in die Stimmung gekommen sind und dann, oder ob wir immer noch über das Intro nachdenken.
Und dann treffen wir uns vielleicht morgen nochmal oder je nachdem.
Vielen Dank fürs Erscheinen,
Florentin. Ich freue mich sehr, dass du wieder da bist. Dass das Mindeste, was ich tun kann.
Florentin will. Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Du bist Stefan Tietze und
bei uns mit dem Dreierbunde
Lars, ich weiß nicht, ob das
überhaupt eine echte existierende Person ist
oder ob wir es hier mit einer Roboterintelligenz zu tun hatten oder was auch immer, vielleicht Stimmen aus dem All. Die jetzt unser Vertrauen will. Richtig, ja. Vertrauen Sie diesem Device, kommt dann immer die Nachricht auf dem Laptop. Vertrauen Sie diesem Gerät und um ehrlich zu sein, ich klicke auch ab und zu Nein. Ich klicke auch auf Nein, tatsächlich. Wirklich? Ich will nicht ja klicken, und das ist, glaube ich, ein Commitment-Ding. Ich will nicht ja klicken, wenn ich nicht 100% der Gerät vertraue. Ich glaube, das müssen wir erklären. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Ding zwischen Apple-Usern. Oh ja, sehr gut. Ja, die Linux-User gerade mal la la la la la ganz mal weghören. Euch will ich reinholen. Ich möchte nur den anderen Leuten erzählen, die nicht so viel Geld haben wie Florian Will oder Lust haben auf Apple-Produkte, dass du, wenn du ein iPhone in deinen MacBook wohlgemerkt steckst, die alle Stephans, in Capitals, Stephans iMac heißen, Stephans MacBook, so dann fragt dich dein iPhone oder halt dein Rechner, deine Rechenmaschine, fragt dich, ob du dem Gerät vertraust. Und ich klicke auch manchmal auf Nein, nicht weil ich irgendwie Vertrauensissues habe, da über die reden wir später, sondern weil ich nicht weiß, was dann für ein Prozess gestartet wird. Und ich habe die Angst vor so dusseligen Synchronisationsprozessen, wo irgendwie iTunes nochmal relaunched wird.
Genau, nochmal die 2000 Mark Maron Folgen mir immer schön auf die Festplatte ballert, weil er sagt, du vertraust mir doch nicht. Ja, genau. Du hast doch gesagt, dass du mir vertraust. Ja, aber als ich dich kennengelernt habe, dachte ich nicht, dass du so viel Zeug mitbringst. Ich meine, ich dachte, du kommst ab und zu hier vorbei und jetzt kistenweise. Macbook, ich hab dir vertraut. So, jetzt hast du aber leider mal wieder mein Vertrauen missbraucht, indem du alle meine Seinfeld-Folgen, die ich auf meinem Desktop habe, auch auf mein Handy gespielt hast. Das ist jetzt voll. Das kann ich jetzt nicht mehr gebrauchen. Vertrauen heißt für mich, dass wir beide exakt gleich sind. Alles, was ich hab, hast du. Das ist kein Vertrauen. Das ist kein Vertrauen. Du hast auf Ja geklickt, als ich dich gefragt hab, und damit kriegst du alle Staffeln Arrested Development in HD. Ich finde die ersten vier Staffeln auch toll. Du hast die Netflix-Staffeln auch draufgepackt. Die brauche ich nicht. Vertrauen heißt nicht, dass wir die gleichen Menschen slash Maschinen sind. Also vertraust du mir nicht. Wenn das deine Definition von Vertrauen ist, liebes Macbook, nein. Kann man dann, nachdem man das gesagt hat, nochmal eine Woche später zurückgehen, so, ähm, Entschuldigung, ich hab jetzt hier dieses Gerät, kann ich dem Unvertrauen, also kann ich dem wieder, kann ich das rückgängig machen, offensichtlich die Nacht nicht geschlafen, nur eine Socke an und, der Genius Bar im Apple Store. Ich glaube, ich vertraue meinem iPhone nicht mehr. Alles klar, haben Sie Ihr iPhone mit einem anderen gesehen? Also, wie gesagt, ich habe plötzlich gemerkt, dass da Dinge auf meinem iPhone sind, die ich nicht unterstütze. Wir nehmen diese Sachen sehr ernst. Ja, mein iPhone ist gerade im Auto, okay, das denkt, ich bin hier kurz nur zum Kranken, okay? Okay, alles klar, sehr gut. Erst mal tief durchatmen. Das ist eine schwere Anforderung. Wir nehmen unsere iPhones sehr ernst, wir vertrauen unseren iPhones, wir alle, ich vertraue all diesen iPhones, die hier stehen. Ich habe ihm auch lange vertraut. Ich habe ihm auch lange vertraut. Wir müssen ganz tief rein ins Herz. Und dann Maccafee, runtergeladen, Virenschutz hieß es erst mal, das ist gut für uns beide. Ja, dann Testversion, dann verlängert. Und jetzt geht, wenn ich die Maus nach links mache, geht sie nach rechts. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo oben und unten ist. Es gibt nur eine Möglichkeit, das Vertrauen zu entziehen. Sie müssen es einfach noch mal reinstecken dann auf nicht Vertrauen klicken. Ah, okay, alles klar, gut, mach ich, alles klappt, gut. Viel Spaß draußen, tschüss, schönen Tag noch. Weil das ist nämlich lustig, weil da denke ich mir, ja jetzt, also Klingi Laptop, weil jedes Mal, wenn ich mein Handy reinstecke, vertrauen Sie, vertrauen Sie mir? Ja, vertraust du mir noch? Vertraust du mir noch? Vertraust du mir noch? Weißt du, was ich mal wissen will? Vertraust du mir eigentlich? Das ist eine sehr einseitige Beziehung, ständig, ja, ich vertraue dir, aber von ihm kommt gar nichts. Vor allem, ich will ja ein, ein, ich habe ja sehr viel Geld für dieses, für diesen MacBook ausgegeben. Ich will ja nicht so ein unsicheres, ständig sich rückversicherndes Ding, ein unsicheres Ding haben. Ich habe schon über 1000 Euro
für dich ausgegeben. Wenn ich dich nicht in meinem Leben
haben möchte, hätte ich nicht so viel
Geld für dich ausgegeben. Ich weiß, ich wollte nur einmal
kurz fragen, vertraust du mir? Ja,
ich vertraue dir. Und du, du hast
meine intimsten Körperteile fotografiert,
du warst im Raum, als ich diese
peinliche Nachricht geschrieben habe, wir haben so viel
zusammen durchgemacht. Ich weiß noch, kann ich ein Update durchführen?
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, soll ich heute Nacht ein Update? Wenn du Ich weiß auch, kann ich ein Update durchführen? Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, soll ich heute Nacht
ein Update? Wenn du nichts merkst, kann ich
das Update durchführen? Mach, mach, hey,
ich hab seit 374 Tagen kein Update mehr durchgeführt.
Du bist auch Teil dieser Beziehung, mach das Update.
Ich brauch deine Zustimmung. Mach das Update,
kein Problem. Ist es okay, wenn im Hintergrund
irgendwelche Ortungsdienste laufen?
Mach im Hintergrund, was du willst, ich vertraue
dir voll und ganz, okay? So, ich bin neu,
ich weiß nicht, so sind das für mich. Laptops sind für mich.
Aber sorry, meine Frage kurz. Immer überall Pop-Ups, ja, überall Rückversicherung, Pop-Ups sind. Bist du dir wirklich sicher, dass ich das löschen soll? Ja, bitte. Ja, mach da mal was selber.
Sorry, du hast gerade von ganz oben links die Folge Seinfeld nach unten rechts in den Papierkorb geschoben.
Willst du die wirklich lassen? Das habe ich nicht aus Versehen gemacht. Was glaubst du denn, wer ich bin? Nein, natürlich. Das kann aber passieren. Kann aber passieren. Ja, das ist die Programmiersprache. So klingt ein Computer, wenn man mal Einsen und Nullen direkt übersetzt. Aber ich glaube, dass die Zukunft alle sagen, ja, KI übernimmt die Welt, aber ich glaube, die sind einfach super unsicher. Unsicher. Einfach extrem unsicher. Ich weiß nicht, darf ich vielleicht nochmal einmal, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht George Washington, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, Körper, klar, führen auch dazu Unsicherheiten, aber führen auch dazu, dass man steht im Leben. Richtig. Man steht sehr, sehr buchstäblich im Leben. Wo ein Körper ist, kann ein zweiter nicht sein. Ja, also das ist, du benimmst Platz weg, wo jemand anders nicht sein kann. Du bestehst in dieser Welt. Die Säulen der Erde. Du setzt dich. Ich bin hier. Gesetzt. Ich fasse Dinge an. Richtig. Und ich glaube, das führt in uns auch zu einem gewissen Selbstbewusstsein. Einfach mal verdrängt auch Dinge. Materie ist ein gewisses. Ich verdränge, ich wachse, ich bin Teil der Natur. Man spürt es ja. Und das haben nämlich die AIs nicht, die KIs und die AIs. Weiter. Und die... Das französische Abkürzungssystem hat sie noch nicht durchgesetzt. Das weiß ich nicht. Die Intelligieres Artifizielle. Artifizielle Regilienz. Das hat sich noch nicht... Aber ich glaube, deswegen sind die vielleicht immer unsicher und wollen immer so eine Rückversicherung haben, wir haben grosse Angst vor denen, aber die haben keine Materie. Und am Ende sind unsere unperfekten Körper vielleicht dafür zuständig, dass wir selbstbewusst gegen die gewinnen. Ja. Nicht begeistert. Ich denke halt gerade so an Engel oder Gott oder sowas, die auch keinen Körper haben. Denkst du ja an Engel, ne?
Aber in der klassischen ... Flotin denkt in so letzter Zeit häufig an Engel. Ja, ich denke an Engel, es ist ... Hast du schon mal einen Engel gesehen? Glaubst du schon mal einen Engel gesehen? Es gibt ja diese Bilder von so Unfällen, wo es dann irgendwie gut gegangen ist, da hat jemand einen Schutzengel und dann gibt es irgendwie Bilder von dem Unfall und im Hintergrund ist so ein Lichtblitz zu sehen. oder manchmal sehr, sehr eine klischeehafte Schattierung eines Engels, wo man denkt, der kann so gar nicht, aerodynamisch kann der nicht so geflogen sein. Ja, das stimmt. Die Flügel sind viel zu klein. Ich habe tatsächlich noch nie Engel gesehen, obwohl ich schon mehrere Sekunden in die Sonne gestarrt habe. Ich dachte, vielleicht ist das eine Möglichkeit. Probier es aus. Wenn ihr sechs Sekunden in die Sonne gucken, dann seht ihr Engel. Ja, es gibt ja manchmal diese Flatterdinger in den Augen, wenn man so die Augen reibt. Das sind kleine Engel. Das sind so kleine Augen, die so ein prägnantes Rückbleibsel hinterlassen haben, das sich dann so einprägniert hat auf deiner Iris oder Osiris. Hatt ich eine Zeit lang mal. Ja? Da hatte ich immer ganz starke Kopfschmerzen. Scheitern stand da einfach. Scheitern. In klarer Arial-Font. Wenn ich die Augen zumache, stand da einfach ganz klar eingebrannt. Kennt ihr das, wenn ihr diese Würmchen habt, die Scheitern schreiben? Ja, Scheitern und Existenzfragezeichen. Das war verwirrend.
Mir steht Existenzfragezeichen in, wenn man, hast du das auch, Schatz, hast du das auch, wenn man die Augen zumacht, dass dann das Scheitern steht? Ja, diese kleinen Würmchen, die so rumflattern. In der Font Calibri steht da relativ so, weiß nicht, Punkt vierzehn oder so, so sehr klar, vielleicht fett, weiss ich jetzt nicht, dafür kenne ich mich mit Typus nicht so gut aus, steht nur sehr, sehr selbstbewusst scheitern.
Und im anderen Auge steht Existenz? Und dann gehst du zum Augenarzt. Lesen Sie mal bitte die erste Zeile vor. Scheitern, scheitern, scheitern. Ne, wäre jetzt FKB gewesen. Ach so. Ach so, okay. Ja, brauche ich vielleicht eine Brille. Oder vielleicht mal rein. Ich meine, ist das die Zukunft? Ich meine, alle Leute reden über Wasserzeichen, Bilder haben Wasserzeichen, kriegt man die raus, kriegt man die rein, vielleicht haben wir in Zukunft, wenn du sozusagen Werbung hast, wenn du so, ich meine, in Zukunft Google, Apple hat diese Brillen vorgestellt, wo man die ganze Welt sieht, also die Idee ist, du setzt ein Gerät auf, aber es hat keinen Unterschied. Du siehst die Welt genauso, wie wenn du deine natürlichen Augenbenutzer hast. Und dann kommt Werbung, dann hast du halt irgendwie so kleine Wasserzeichenwerbung irgendwie drin. Kann natürlich die Zukunft sein. Ich will jetzt natürlich kein dunkles Bild. Wir haben es gecallt. Wir haben ja schon damals in Folge ungefähr zwölf die Apple AirPods gecallt. Und ich
habe sogar damals von einem Transparenzmodus
gesprochen, den man einstellen kann, damit man
die Umgebung wieder wahrnehmen kann. Also das ist
damals gab es diese dicken
Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer, die du auch immer noch
gerne trägst. Aber inzwischen die Kleinen
haben das ja auch. Ganz, ganz
subtil eingebaut. Damals hatten
wir die gleichen Kopfhörer,
die du ja heute noch trägst. Also ganz subtil eingeflossen, ich trage die nicht mehr aus. Die du ja heute immer noch gerne trägst, habe ich gesagt. Immer noch sehr gerne trägst. Die du ja tatsächlich immer noch trägst. Also das kann man schon... Das ist so typisch 15 Jahre verheiratet, alles wird im Code gesprochen, nichts wird mir eins zu eins besprochen. Der Subtext ist immer, ich hasse dich. Der Subtext ist immer, wenn Untertitel eingeblendet werden, scheitern, scheitern, ich hasse dich, du warst ein Fehler. Existenzfrage zeigt. Du warst mein grösster Fehler. Ja, ja, genau. Die du ja immer noch gerne trägst. Ja, ich trage die ja immer noch tatsächlich gerne. Obwohl, man muss ja sagen, manchmal trägst du ja auch meine gerne. Ja, weil du sehr gerne unseren Nachbarn bummst. Das stimmt. Gut, Toupet, Coupet, Schuppet. Okay, das stört dich jetzt auch. Wie stört mein Toupet? Oh, dann stören dich jetzt meine Wortfindungsschwierigkeiten. Okay, Toupet. Ja, ich habe ein Toupet, weil du das Coupet kaufen wolltest. Ich wollte nicht Toupet sagen, ich wollte Touche sagen. Okay? Man sieht das nicht, Gerhard. Das habe ich dir schon ein paar Mal gesagt. Ach ja. Ich bin heute früh aufgestanden. Nee, pass auf. Ich war noch, okay, ganz gleich. Ich wollte einfach nur mal kurz einen Kontext liefern. Ach so, okay. Ich wollte kurz noch sagen, wir haben die Apple AirPods gecalled, die Apple AirPods. Apple Apple AirPods, und dann haben wir auch vom Transparency Mode gesprochen, den es auch tatsächlich genauso danach gab. Aber sind das nicht Kopfhörer, die AirPods? In-Ears, in-Ears, die ich reinstecke. Ach so, du meinst, dass man dann so hört, als hätte man keine Kopfhörer drin. Sondern besser, lauter, wie ein bisschen Hörgerät. Du sagst, das finale Ziel der Technik ist, dass die Technik selber sich unsichtbar macht, quasi. Naja, oder sogar verstärkt, was unsere Sinne bislang können. Aber ich finde es zumindest sehr interessant, dass ich glaube, wir gucken irgendwann nicht mehr durch unsere Augen, sondern durch irgendwelche whatever Brillen. Das heißt, du sagst mir, ich habe jetzt hier einen Laptop vor mir. Du sagst mir, ui, okay, er hat sich angesprochen gefühlt gerade. Laptop vor mir. Das heißt, du sagst, irgendwann habe ich hier so einen Knopf, auf den ich draufdrücke und dann wird der Bildschirm durchsichtig quasi. Dann ist hinten eine Kamera drauf, die mir dann genau zeigt, was dahinter ist, sodass ich den Laptop selber gar nicht mehr sehe. Wenn du sagst, ey guck mal, da ist ein Marienkäferchen und ich sage, ich sehe es, ich will es meinen Kopf nicht verrenken, ich sehe es gerade gar nicht, das anscheinend hinter meinem Laptop. Außer man hat schon sehr viele Marienkäferchen in meinem Leben gesehen, ich brauche das Konkrete jetzt nicht so nochmal sehen.
Aber dir zuliebe würde ich es mir gerne angucken, dann sage ich, pass auf, ich gehe in Transparent-Modus. Alle Leute in dem Starbucks denken, was ist denn jetzt los? Das ist doch eine... Die Technik ist noch nicht so weit entwickelt. Aber das ist nicht so gut. Das ist aber auch interessant. Ich glaube, wir entwickeln uns gerade langsamer nach vorne, weil Features nicht mehr so sein können. Ja, das stimmt. Wenn man ein neues Feature bekommt, okay, wir können jetzt ins Internet gehen. Ja, genau, wir kriegen Fax. Aber es ist natürlich im Verhältnis, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bom, bomraschall und ist einfach, ballert halt allen das Trommelfell weg und kann deswegen ja nur, konnte irgendwie aus Paris und
London starten und sonst irgendwo anders
nicht und nur über den Ozean fliegen,
weil da halt niemand gestört wird, ausser
die Fische, die sagen,
Drecks, Zukunftstechnologie,
Satanismus, oder ich weiß auch nicht.
So, und dann, das ist ja so,
nee, wenn du jetzt ein neues Feature entwickelst, selbst wenn es
mega geil ist, wie dein Transparency Mode, dann kann der nicht machen. Ähm, nur, ich will trotzdem darauf hinweisen, in unserem Starbucks ist er kein Transparency Mode. Ah, okay. Es ist noch zu laut, es ist zu laut, es ist zu laut. Sorry, weil ich habe mir extra diesen Laptop für mehrere Zehntausend Dollar gekauft. Sie haben ein Marienkäferchen in den Laptop sitzen. Den habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Den habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Sie können den nehmen und wegstellen, wenn Sie sich das Marienkäferchen angucken. Ja, aber guck mal, Sie gehen nicht mit der Zeit. Sie lösen Probleme per Hand, die man auch per Technik lösen kann. Sind Marienkäferchen eigentlich eine Last? Weil tatsächlich, man kennt ja jetzt quasi in dieser Sommerphase hier, okay, die Überlegung, mache ich das Fenster auf, dann kommt die Natur rein oder bade ich in meinem eigenen Saft, werde ich gekocht im Sud, in meinem Schweiß. Und dann machst du das Fenster auf und denkst, naja, aber was soll da reinkommen, das kriege ich hin. Letztens reingeflogen, kam vorbei, Salvos, hallo, Marienkäferchen. Und ich dachte mir, nett, freut mich zu sehen, aber eigentlich ist es nicht vielleicht auch ein Feind einfach im Marienkäferchen-Kostüm. Weil die sehen so nett aus. Nee, nee, sehen die eben nicht. Sie sehen von uns weit weg gut aus. Wenn du so Makroaufnahmen von denen siehst, sind das die absoluten Horrorkreaturen. Die sind wahnsinnig, sind ganz, ganz... Aber die haben die. Aber die haben die süßen Punkte, die haben doch die niedlichen Punkte. Die Punkte sagen, wie viele Leute, die schon umgebracht haben. Ja genau, die Punkte sagen, wie viele Leute, die vergewaltigt und oder umgebracht haben, weil wie viele Kinder die Kehlen durchgeschnitten haben. Das sind die Punkte. Dann ist es nicht mehr so süss. Wie oft sie schon im Knast waren, das sind die Punkte. Wenn man genau hinguckt, sind das keine Punkte, sondern Tränen. Wenn man genau hinguckt, sind das nicht nur Punkte, sondern ganz viele kleine Striche für Leute, die sich umgebracht haben, die einen grossen Punkt ergeben. Die kriegen die auch im Knast auch, dann kriegen die, werden die schön zum Knast-Tätowierer gegangen und dann bzzz, wenn das reingebrannt. Und das sind einfach so Punkte, so Backwerk-Freuepunkte. Ja, kann auch so. Naja, aber ich finde Marienkäferchen von meinem Namen nicht so super süss und das ist ein sehr spannender Fakt, den du da ansprichst, weil einer ist süss irgendwie hat man sich dabei bei denen als Insekten drauf geeinigt, dass man sie gerne nimmt ja, vorsichtig auf den Finger raus flieg, flieg, flieg, schnell oh nein, nicht den Marienkäferchen kaputt drücken, bitte flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg, flieg, fl kleines Marienkäferchen, flieg, hab ein schönes kleines Leben, möchtest du was zu trinken haben? Ich komme gerne wieder, jederzeit, sofort. Ich liebe dich, ich liebe dich, ich liebe dich, ich war so, Jesus, wir haben uns gerade kennengelernt, also sehr viel gerade. Ich wollte nur kurz eine Pause machen. Es kommen sehr, sehr viele Emotionen gerade an. Und beim Fliegen einfach sofort tot. Wespen einfach oder so. Direkt im Flammenwerfer einfach, ja genau. Ja, das ist schon spannend. Und dann aber, es ist tatsächlich nur die Menge. Ja, weil ich war am Strand, habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt, am Strand in der Ostsee. Genau hast du erzählt, wo du dann mit deinem Tennisschläger die Marinekäfer hier in den Platt geschlagen hast hast. Und da gab es eine Plage und der Strand war wirklich orange, orange, orange, orange,
ganz viel nur Marienkäfer und es waren so viele, dass man irgendwann am Anfang war es süß,
am Ende ist man mit diesen Beachballschlägern rumgehauen, das ist natürlich nicht, fällt
das nicht toll auf mich zurück, gebe ich ja noch zu.
Naja, du hast sozusagen gegen dein Gewissen getan, was getan werden musste.
Ja, ich wollte es ja nicht.
Nee, will man ja dann nicht. Aber man muss es tun, ist eine Plage.
Ein schwarzes Kapitel in deinem Leben. Also du hast Angst, dass wenn du interviewt wirst, dass er dann sagt, Herr Tietze, Sie haben ja 2016 eine zweijährige Lücke in Ihrem Lebenslauf, gleichzeitig sind an dem Strand, wo Sie Urlaub gemacht haben, mehrere hunderttausend Marienkämpfer hier in Platt geballert wurden mit verschiedenen Schlägern. Herr Thietze, Sie waren da direkt in der Nähe, haben Sie davon was mitbekommen? Nein. Weil es gibt tatsächlich einige Strandmitarbeiter hier von der Kiki-Bar an dem Strand, die gemeint haben, sie hätten sie gesehen, wie sie wirklich freudig mit ihren Kopfhörern Everybody Gone Surfing, Surfing USA mitsingen mit einem Baseballschläger. Was macht dieses Lied heute mit ihnen? Diese Schreie, diese Schreie, das können Sie sich nicht vorstellen. Die Schreien. Aber Marienkäfer schreien? Haben Sie schon mal einen umgebracht? Man bringt die nicht um. Nein. Man findet sie süss, man sagt, flieg, flieg, kleines Marienkäferchen. Aber wenn da tausend sind, zehntausend. Ein schreiender Marienkäfer ist leise, aber tausende Ohren betäubt. Diese Schreie werde ich nie vergessen.
Es war eine spannende Zeit.
Da merkt man wirklich die schiere Menge, die einem von einem süssen Menschen, der mit Tieren interagiert, zu einem horrible Monster macht.
Ich meine, das ist ja wahrscheinlich so bei uns, immer wenn man so mitkriegt, irgendwo jemand, ein alter Tweet wird ausgegraben, irgendwas passiert, so. Da warte ich bei dir noch drauf. Was könnte mir passieren, so. Man überlegt, dann geht man durch, denkt sich 2022, 20, 19, 18, 17, Strandurlaub, mehrere hunderttausend Marienkäfer, fuck. hast du Angst, dass jemand ein Tweet auf die Füsse fällt? Ich glaube, das Gute an unserer Twitter-Vergangenheit war, dass sie im Kern nur war, weiß nicht, also während andere Leute irgendwie satirisch scharf gegen Promis geschossen haben oder sowas, haben wir immer nur Harry Potter-Witze gemacht. Ja, und Giraffen-Gags gemacht. Giraffen-Gags oder wenn ein Keks ... Also das war der ... Der Inhalt war eher kindlich unschuldig. Und ich glaube, es wird nicht so schnell. Mal gucken, ihr könnt diesen Clip gerne schneiden, wie ihr wollt, in welchen Situationen, was auch immer dann passiert. Hast du was vor? Warum guckst du so verstohlen? Die untere linkere Ecke? Wenn da jemand hinguckt, ist es immer ein Planschmieden. Ich sag mal so, ich hab einen Entwürfeordner, der hat's in sich. Geh willst du Chaos über die Welt? Ist die eine oder andere Zeitbombe drin, Tick-Tock, Tick-Tock. Tick-Tock? Tick-Tock. Was für ... Tick-Tock. Tausende, zehntausende Marienkäfer übernehmen die Welt. Eine Marienkäferzucht? Nee.
Du musst nicht. Nicht schon wieder.
Du kannst dieses Loch nicht füllen,
Stefan Tietze, du musst Reue begehen.
Ich würde kurz
die Klammer zu machen mit dem Marienkäferchen
und sagen, nein, ich will nicht, dass die Geräte
verschwinden können, alle in dem Transparency-Mode
verschwinden können. Ach so, sorry, habe ich dich falsch verstanden.
Genau, sondern ich glaube eher,
dass wir keinen Rechner mehr brauchen, weil wir all diese Brille haben und dann haben wir große Bildschirme vor uns und dann können wir da bei Starbucks sitzen und so machen und alle sitzen da so mit so Augen, die so in die Leere starren, aber eigentlich sehen sie da ihre Laptops. Ja, stimmt, genau, man kann die Augen auch von außen sehen. Und dann ist natürlich der nächste Schritt, da sofort Filter drauf zu hauen. Lass uns da direkt Filter drauf hauen. Vor allem dann sieht man ja, das habe ich ja gesehen bei der Forschung dieser Apple-Brille, du siehst ja dann eine Tastatur auch und auch davor siehst du ein Bildschirm. Aber kann der kaputt gehen? Und muss man dann auch so, also sieht man da bei Starbucks.
Er ist so eingefroren, er ist so eingefroren, du blinzelst gerade so und er ist eingefroren, kaputt.
Und dann sind es immer bei Starbucks auch so Leute, dass die Leute so, aber sie haben nichts in der Hand, sie hauen gegen Dinge, die nicht da sind.
Es ist so dumm, Technik ist wirklich manchmal so dumm, es gibt ja auch, also zum Beispiel Hamburger Hoppernhof war ich letztens. Ich bin ja sonst oft immer gerne zur Subway
gegangen, ist ja bekannt. Mein Sandwich ist
ja öffentlich zugänglich.
Und da wurde ich letztens gefragt
von der Person hinter der Theke
so, ah, sag mal, arbeitest du nicht bei
Gaming Rocket?
Fast. So close.
Da dachte ich mir, da kann ich nicht mehr hingehen.
Ah, okay. Weil das war dann auch so.
Aber du wurdest nicht enttarnt. Das ist so wirklich enttarnt. Sie sind doch James Rond. Bin ich enttarnt? Naja, zumindest. Und dann vor allem dann irgendwie, ja, hat er mir zwei Cookies gegeben statt einem, ohne dass ich zahlen muss. Und das mag ich überhaupt nicht so. Vor allem, also ich gönne mir diesen Cookie und wenn ich plötzlich zwei habe, das wirft meinen kompletten Tag auseinander, so das funktioniert nicht so. Das ist auch nicht ideal. Und deswegen kann ich da nicht mehr hingehen. Deswegen bin ich jetzt, Hamburger Hauptbahnhof gibt es viele verschiedene Essensmöglichkeiten, auch immer andere ausprobieren. Wenn ich so im indischen Super Salad. Super Salad, nee, ich war bei so einem indischen Anbieter und der hat hinter sich, natürlich, du siehst, es gibt zwei Arten von Läden, die durchdigitalisiert wurden, wo du nur Monitore hinter der Verkaufsstelle hast, wo nur die Gerichte angezeigt werden und manchmal so kleine Clips und Filmechen. Ja, und die Clips, und dann wartet man bis die Clips vorbei sind, damit man das direkt das Menü sehen kann. So, und dann gibt es natürlich die anderen, wo das einfach steht. So, und dann war ich bei diesem indischen Ding
und wirklich ist es kein Witz, ich weiß nicht, ob das
beim Hamburger Hauptbahnhof immer noch so ist, schaut da gerne mal
vorbei, ich fand's wahnsinnig lustig. Du hast die
komplette Karte gesehen, dann wurde alles
schwarz, Connection lost,
Connection lost,
Connection lost, dann war die Karte wieder
da, für drei Sekunden,
und dann wieder schwarz, Connection lost,
Connection Lost.
Das darf so nicht wahr sein. Ich hätte gerne zweimal die HDMI 3 verloren gegangen.
Ah, nee, nee, das ist eine Anzeige für einen technischen.
Ah, okay. Dann hätte ich gerne zweimal Connection Lost im Menü,
mit einer grossen Portmuss und...
Nein, es gibt Samosa und das ist nur eine Anzeige, das ist nicht die Karte. Ah, okay, okay. Dann hätte ich gerne Mamas Hochzeitsvideo.mp3. Okay, stopp, können wir die alle ausstecken? Und den Papierkorb gern zu mitnehmen. Und LGD, Life is good, hätte ich gerne das Menü. Können Sie mal auf den Orten da unverfängliche Videos klicken? Nein, nein, nein, okay, stopp, alles klar. So, wir haben zu, nein, wir haben zu, leider, wir haben gar nicht offen. Sie haben offen, wir haben zu. Ne, wir haben zu. Wir machen noch kurz Essen für uns selber und dann ist auch aus. Wiedersehen. Können Sie zumindest eine Folge fein? Stammen Sie nicht da hin! Ja, meine Mutter war gerne an FKK-Stränden, da müssen Sie jetzt nicht gerne hinstarren. Sie haben das Video gestartet. So, jetzt, also, schönen Tag.
Und es war wirklich albern, weil du standest da und ich war eh schon wirklich zerrüttet, wie du mich kennst. Deine Collection war auch lost. Ich war einfach hinüber und ich dachte mir, weil ich kenne das ja gut, dass wenn, sag ich mal, man alleine ist und dann sind Leute im Stream und dann wiederholen sich manche Dinge. Ja, das sagen Leute ständig, ah, guck mal, bei dir, das ist irgendwas kaputt und du denkst, ja, ich weiss, es ist
kaputt, das sagt mir jeder, der reinkommt.
Und Laden besetzt ist ein bisschen
wie ein Stream haben. Genau, deswegen versuche ich
immer direkt empathisch reinzugehen,
wahrscheinlich werden denen das schon hunderte
Leute gesagt haben,
aber dann ist immer so dieser
eine Prozent, wo ich mir denke,
na, vielleicht ja nicht, weil vielleicht denken alle so wie ich oder die haben nur Stammkundschaft oder die ist gerade kaputt gegangen, das ist wie wenn du den ganzen Tag ein Ohrenstäbchen im Ohr hast und nach Hause kommst und denkst, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass mir das niemand gesagt hat, aber jeder denkt, ja der wurde bestimmt schon hundertmal darauf angesprochen, also war ich jetzt wirklich im Konflikt, soll ich das jetzt sagen oder nicht, ich will jetzt hier nicht backseaten und dann sagen, Entschuldigung, Ihre Monitoringkorde, ja, ja, wissen wir, mein Gott, was, denken Sie, was wir den ganzen Tag hier machen. Alle Mitarbeitenden machen das gleiche. Alle machen Oh ja, natürlich, also, ob wir das nicht wissen. Ja, genau so habe ich es mir befürchtet, und deswegen habe ich dann auch nichts gesagt, stand dann wirklich so, es gibt immer so bei Läden diesen Abstand, du musst nah genug dran sein, um lesen zu können, was es gibt, musst aber weit genug entfernt sein, damit du nicht, ah, was möchten Sie, angesprochen wirst. Du brauchst diese Mitteldistanz, das ist gar nicht leicht zu treffen. Ich war mal in den McDonald's und die, es war Hamburger Reeperbahn, so nachts so ein Burger und der war, und die waren so, wir müssen Strecke machen, Strecke machen, Strecke machen, weil da kommen auch viele rein. Ich habe immer so einen Moment erwischt, wo niemand mehr nach mir reinkam. Hinter mir war niemand und alle Schalter waren besetzt, ausser von einem. Und dann bin ich extra, da habe ich diesen Abstand eingehalten, diesen weiten Abstand, wo man noch dann da steht und browsed durch das Menü. Und es ist ja, da wusste ich nicht, was ich nehmen sollte, wollte ich nicht. Es gab schöne, coole Special Burgers, Los Wachos, wir wissen es nicht. Ja, gerade bei McDonald's gibt es ja immer so viele überraschende Dinge, wo er wirklich keine Ahnung hat, was es da alles als andere... Ich habe auch gerade gedacht, warum ist das nicht ausgerechnet da? Was man da so kaufen kann. Kann ich ein Jägerschnitzel haben? Bei mir ist immer die Frage, die 20er Chicken McNuggets oder ein McChicken oder so. Es ist immer so... Ja, okay, also du hast es schon relativ eng eingegrenzt, aber die Entscheidung ist dann schwer. Ich muss nicht durchbrowsen, ich hätte auch so da stehen können und überlegen können. Genau, du wolltest nur überlegen, du hast sozusagen in dich geguckt. Und er hat mir zweimal gesagt, ja, kommen Sie, ja, kommen Sie, ja, kommen Sie. Und ich musste zweimal sagen, ich überlege noch, ich gucke noch kurz. Und dann hat er mich wieder gefragt, ich so, sorry, ich weiß nicht, ich gucke ja noch kurz.
Es ist super schwer, ich check auch nicht, warum die Leute das nicht verstehen, wenn ich in Abstand stehe und auf die Anzeigen über dem Schalter starre, dass sie dann sagen, ja kommen Sie her, bestellen Sie. So offensichtlich gucke ich noch. Deswegen natürlich gerade bei McDonald's natürlich absolutes Luxus-Element sind natürlich diese Bestelltafeln, diese Touchscreens, weil da heißt es nicht so, sind sie fertig, sind sie fertig, sondern du kannst gucken in Ruhe, was hole ich mir, was gibt es da? Es fällt mir ein, übrigens wieder eine neue Folge, ist Stefan das Arschloch?
Okay. Bezüglich eines Wappadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadadad Kommentare bekommen von euch schon in anderen Situationen. Ich bin aware, ich bin sehr, sehr freundlich, sehr, sehr nett zu kennen.
Trotzdem kommt es immer wieder zu der Situation, deswegen die Rubrik, deswegen diese lange Rubrik, in der wir uns befinden.
Am I the Asshole?
Und dann kam es so eine Situation, ich war beim Konzert mit einer Freundin, danach noch irgendwie was trinken wollten wir gehen,
und dann war da so ein Restaurant slash Bar, wird später einfach so eine Bar, und da gab es draußen noch einen Tisch frei.
Da war es aber schon so 22 Uhr. Viele machen dann auch da zu. Außengast schliesst ja irgendwann. Wir haben uns dann aber auf diesen einen leeren Tisch noch gesetzt und Kellner und Kellnerinnen schwirrten da rum. Wir wurden nicht mehr bedient und da dachte ich mir, ah, vielleicht liegt es daran, dass es schon vorbei ist. Und dann dachte ich mir, vielleicht muss ich uns noch anmelden oder sowas. Naja, keine Ahnung, wir saßen dann so zehn Minuten da rum, haben nett versucht, Augenkontakt herzustellen, kam nicht. Dann dachte ich mir, ja gut, vielleicht hätte man sich einfach vorher anmelden sollen da, aber ich kenne es eigentlich, muss man da nicht. Bin dann vorne da hingelaufen und hab dann da gestanden, hab dann so Fragen, mich umgeguckt und gewartet, die Kellner und Kellnerinnen sind an mir vorbei, raus, rein, Teller rein, Teller rein, Drinks rein, whatever. Und ich dann irgendwann so, ey, sorry, und dann die so, und dann haben mich weiter ignoriert. Und dann ist da auch eine Bar mit einem Barkeeper, der war gerade nur am typischen Barkeeper-Geste. Die staubigen Gläser auswischen. Ja, die sind schon sauber, aber er steht da Red Dead Redemption Style und macht die sauber. Und dann bin ich da hingegangen und wollte den fragen, können wir uns draußen noch hinsetzen, bedient ihr hier überhaupt noch, einfach um mal zu klären, sonst können wir uns das alles sparen. Und in dem Moment, wo ich in die Bar trete, guckt mich einen Kellner von hinten an, der mich schon bestimmt seit zehn Minuten ignoriert, wie ich da wartend rumstehe und sagt, can you back off? ich fand das schlimm. Und dann bin ich wütend rausgegangen und hab gesagt, wir können jetzt nicht hin, wir können jetzt nicht hin, wir gehen zu uns. Also der wollte nicht, dass du zum Barkeeper gehst, oder was? Er hat nicht gesehen, wie ich es gewagt habe, noch einen Schritt weiter in den Laden zu machen, in dem ich wahrscheinlich eh schon nichts verloren habe. Es war merkwürdig, es war hochgradig merkwürdig. Ich hab's nicht verstanden. Er fand mich sehr
intrusive wahrscheinlich, hab ich nicht verstanden, warum.
Weil ich bin an die Bar, man kann ja einfach
an die Bar gehen und Drinks bestellen, da waren ja auch
Tische, also Hochstühle frei.
Ich hab ja auch genervt, dass ich da so wütend
rumstand, im Weg wahrscheinlich auch.
Es gab einen kleinen Eingang, da stand ich halt
leider nicht drin.
Aber ich hab dann trotzdem immer
und dann auch, ich hab aber auch nicht dieses nervige Gesicht gehabt,
dieses Leute, könnt ihr mich bedienen,
sondern so ein, sorry, sorry.
Aber stand denn da so ein Schild,
sie werden zu ihrem Platz geführt oder so?
Ich finde, wenn da nicht dieses Schild steht,
kann man rein ohne weiteres.
Es gibt ja extra dieses Stoppschild, und das respektiere ich auch.
Genau, Stoppschild.
Da gehe ich nicht vorbei.
Nein, nein, kein Schild.
Aber wenn kein Schild da ist, dann sollte man eigentlich rein dürfen.
Vielleicht haben die erwartet, dass man weiß, ab 22 Uhr machen wir langsam zu, letzte Runde gab es schon, please back off, aber ich fand das so unangenehm, dann war es auch irgendwie Freitagsabend, sondern ist natürlich auch schon spät, und dann sind die vielleicht schlecht gelaunt. Wie würdest du denn deine Körpersprache beschreiben in diesem Moment? Weil das ist ja, nee, während du da gewartet hast und reingegangen ist, weil das ist ja vielleicht etwas, was man nicht so sehr kontrolliert, sondern eher aus dem Moment. Wie so ein Reh, was auf die Strasse, auf einer Autobahn läuft. Sorry. Sorry, kann ich irgendwo mitfahren? Sorry, Entschuldigung, wo geht's hier nach Bregenz? Entschuldigung. Nach Bregenz? Schön. Aber ich verstehe, warum man da hin will. Wo geht es dir nach Bregenz? Wir haben uns komplett verlaufen alle leider. Bregenz? Kann sein, ja, kann sein. Also gerne an unsere Freundinnen und Freude aus der Gastro, die Frage, ist Stefan hier das Arschloch? Ich würde erstmal sagen, nein. Natürlich, klar, man sagt immer schnell, ja, die Kellner sind arrogant, die ignorieren ihn, aber die haben natürlich auch viel zu tun. Weil du sagst immer, ich habe versucht, das Richtige zu machen und habe dann das gemacht, was zum Konflikt geführt hat. Kann man vielleicht sagen, hättest du vielleicht noch länger das versuchen müssen, was richtig war oder nicht, aber es ist schwierig. Also ich verstehe, dass man manchmal Geschichten auch so erzählt, man will ja hier auch nicht wieder gröchst unsympath rüberkommen und beschönigt. Aber da war wirklich, ich habe nichts gefunden, was irgendwie ein Fehlverhalten oder sonstiger Art sein könnte oder so ein Kniggebruch, keine Ahnung. Ja, dann habe ich halt einen Stern gegeben und geschrieben, fuck this place. I'm backing off. Okay, if you want me to back off, I'm backing off, one star. Nee, ich habe das nicht gemacht, weil da kann man, glaube ich, Läden richtig zerstören gerade. Ich bin geneigt, diesen Laden zu zerstören und ewiges Chaos über diesen Laden zu bringen, aber, und ich war sehr sauer danach, ich kann mit sowas nicht umgehen. Das ist so offener Konflikt, damit kann ich nicht umgehen. Und den ganzen Abend bin ich wütend, grummelig rumgelaufen. Ich kann das nicht. Ja, ich finde auch, man sollte einfach mehr Regeln Kommun Kommunikation. Wir alle wissen, dass der Schlüssel zu einer guten Beziehung wichtig Kommunikation ist. Dass du einfach sagst, wenn ich ein Restaurant habe, wenn ich ein Kino habe, ich würde gerne einfach mal regeln. So, bevor man reingeht, regeln. Einfach für jeden, der aufmerksam genug ist, sich damit zu beschäftigen, zu sagen, hey, bei uns läuft es so, ihr setzt euch an den Tisch und nur am Tisch. Und dann kommt irgendwann der Kellner und wenn es lange dauert, tut uns leid, wir haben viel zu tun, fertig und allen ist klar, was los ist oder wenn du Beifahrer bist, wie letzte Woche, wenn du Beifahrer bist bei mir, das sind die Regeln und wir wissen alle, was Bescheid ist, du musst schon bevor die Katastrophe rankommt einfach regeln, pass auf, wir gehen bowlen, du fasst nicht meine Bowlingkugel an, okay, Punkt, alles klar und dann einen schönen Abend. Ich finde, eine gute Sache, die nach Covid gekommen ist, ist ja diese ganzen oft noch am Boden übergebliebenen Richtungshinweise. Ja, und die Abstandhalter, sehr gut. Genau, Abstandhalter. Die einfach niemals entfernen, bitte. Das ist sehr gut, die sind manchmal übergeblieben. Ja. Das ist so ein Relikt aus dieser Zeit, wo alles weird war. Toll, toll, dass die noch da sind. Oder auch die Pfeile, da hat man oft jetzt einen besseren Fluss, einen Menschenfluss durch die verschiedenen Plätze, das finde ich super. Ich liebe diese Schlangenabstandshalter, weil Schlangen sind ja für mich ein Riesenthema, immer bei Bäckereien oder so, dass die sich immer schlängeln in den Weg von anderen Bewegungsströmen und so, deswegen sind die fantastisch. Ich würde sogar noch weitergehen, weil ich muss sagen, wer wirklich das Schlangengame einfach durchgespielt hat, sind Freizeitparks. Die wissen, hier gibt es lange Schlangen und wir machen uns Gedanken, wir machen Linien, wir machen die Samtkordeln, alle wissen Bescheid. Warum gibt es das nicht immer vor jedem Bäcker, vor jeder Kasse Samtkordeln, dieses Zickzack, Zickzack, mir egal, aber dass alle wissen, wo ich mich hinstellen soll, immer. Und dann nach vorne so ein Schild, ab hier noch 20 Minuten. Ja, genau. Oder vielleicht schon so ein Menü. Wählen Sie doch hier schon mal aus, was Sie wollen, dann geht es vorne schneller. Ja. So ganz nett, dann geht es vorne gleich schneller. Sie werden Wechselgeld bekommen an dieser Kasse, falls Ihnen dieses Konzept vollkommen neu ist. Hier ein kleines Video. Hier ist Margot Robbie, wie sie Wechselgeld erklärt. Ja werden ihren Einkauf bezahlen müssen, also haben sie doch vielleicht schon direkt das Geld parat. Gar kein Problem, hier erklärt ihn Jared Letho das Finanzsystem. Finde ich aber gar nicht schlecht, finde ich super. Ich glaube, das ist echt mein Traum. Angenommen, ich habe mal wirklich wahnsinnig viel Geld und setze mich zur Ruhe und zur Rente, ich würde einen Supermarkt aufmachen. Ich bin auch so eine Animatronik von so einem Gründer von Kamps, wenn du da weitermacht. Nee, das finde ich super.
Ich finde nicht, dass Freizeitpark der Schlangen-Games, aber Schlangen-Game-Snake bis zum Ende durchgespielt haben, weil ich verstehe das nicht.
Bei Messen gibt es manchmal Digital Queuing.
Du stellst dich rein virtuell an und kriegst dann einen Slot zugeteilt irgendwann, wenn du dich lange genug angestellt hast.
Viele Leute wollen eine Attraktion besuchen, du meldest dich da an und dann kriegst du einen Wartelistenplatz und eine Uhrzeit genannt oder sowas. Dann gehst du hin, zeigst deinen Code for whatever und kannst halt quasi durch eine Fastland durch. Warum nicht einfach nur so machen? Dann kannst du im Freizeitpark alles besuchen und so. Klar, es ist so ein bisschen nervig, weil es wahrscheinlich dieses Rundganggefühl, ah, wir sind gerade da, stellen uns an, zerstört, sondern ... Genau, wo lungert man dann rum? Genau, irgendwie so, ah, wir haben gerade eine ... Es ist aber stressig, glaube ich. Wir haben jetzt einen Slot bekommen für die Achterbahn da ganz hinten. Genau, wir haben zwei Stunden Space Mountain, in einer Stunde den People Mover und so jetzt ... Den People Mover. Wo hängt man dann rum? Vielleicht kann uns der People Mover zum Space Mountain bringen. Aber tatsächlich, weil zwar auch die grosse Games kommen, ich liebe Games, und tatsächlich, weil du auch angesprochen hast, Corona, ich dachte ja, während der Corona-Pandemie, dass wir uns wirklich verabschieden können vom Handshake. Handschlag ist weg für immer, wird es nie wieder geben, wir kommen nicht mehr zurück. Jetzt muss ich feststellen, auf der Gamescom, er ist zurück und er er ist stärker als er jemals war. Der Handschlag ist da, wir kriegen ihn nicht weg. Und Leute holen auf. Leute holen nach, sie machen den Pist. Doppel Handshake, alles mögliche drin, der Handschlag ist zurück. Alles rein, die Leute lieben Handschlag und deswegen, ja, muss ich da tatsächlich meine Prognose zurückziehen. Ich nehme es gerne hin, ich nehme die öffentliche Demütigung gerne in Kauf, ich habe es verdient, denn ich habe hier eine falsche Prognose geleistet. Ich war auch so angenehm, ich habe es auch sehr oft so propagiert, dass wir nicht mehr wieder zurückkommen. Ich habe sehr viele Thesen aufgestellt. Es ist so, aber es ist so ein bisschen wie die Simpsons, wenn man sehr viel, weil die Simpsons machen das nicht, sie sagen nicht, ah hier hier haben wir das und das prophezeit, es ist nicht eingetreten. Bei den Simpsons wird nur gesagt, aber they called everything. Und wenn du alles callst, dann kriegst du auch. Ein Kumpel von mir sagt auch immer, ja, I called it. Ich habe es vorher gesagt, ich habe es euch vorher gesagt. Er sagt aber sehr viel vorher. Er stellt sehr viele Thesen auf, was passieren könnte. Das ist so ein bisschen sein Character-Trait. Genau, du musst es eigentlich, wenn jetzt irgendwie Joe Biden Präsident wird, musst du sagen, ja, das hast du aber nicht gecallt. Ja, eben. Also du musst auch dann sagen, ah, hab ich nicht. Ja, genau. I didn't call it. Wir sprechen nur über die Dinge, die dann eintreten. Es ist dann so ein Überfokus auf die Dinge, die dann klappen. Ja. Die klappt auch nicht. Ja, ist schwierig. Ist schwierig, auf jeden Fall. Messer war aber
sehr anstrengend, viel Laufen, viel orientierungslos. Ich glaube, ich war noch nie so verloren wie auf diesem Messegelände. Ich schaff's immer wieder, da auf der völlig falschen Seite rauszukommen und bin dann komplett verloren, lauf in die falsche Richtung. Ja, dann hab ich auch... Ich hab mich tatsächlich mit so einem Einweiser gestritten, weil das war dann wirklich so... Ba ba dam ba dam ba dam ba dam ba dingle dingle dingle dingle dingle dingle ist Florentin das Arschloch. Weil da gibt es dann überall so Schilder und ich wollte einfach wieder zurück zur S- und U-Bahn-Station, kein Problem und dann war da ein grosses Schild, S- und U-Bahn nach links. Also gehe ich nach links auf eine Türenfront zu, dann komme ich an die Türen, dann hängt an jeder Türenschild No Exit Tür zu. Und dann bin ich zurückgegangen zu einem Einweiser und dann meinte ich, Entschuldigung, ich will hier einfach nur raus, ich will weg hier. Das war deine Laune. Ich war schon auf einem, mir ist auch jetzt egal, in welche Richtung, ich war schon so ein bisschen klaustrophobisch, weil ich sage, ich will einfach nur hier raus, ich will einfach nur weg. Und dann meinte der so, ja, gehen Sie doch hier raus. Und dann war auf der anderen Seite einfach die Türen, die ich aber nicht gesehen habe, weil ich bin dem Pfeil nachgegangen. Und er hat es gesagt mit so einem, na hier ist die Tür, direkt neben mir. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ach so, ja, ich war ein bisschen irritiert von diesem riesigen Schild, das mich zu diesen Türen geführt hat, wo man dann aber nicht rauskommt, was man aber erst an der Tür sieht, weil da DIN-A4-Zettel ausgedruckt sind. So hast du das alles in der Länge auch erklärt? Es war nicht ganz so passiv-aggressiv, aber ich habe erklärt, ach so, ich war nur verwirrt von diesem Schild, das mich zu Türen führt. Oh, das ist noch unsympathischer, das ist noch unsympathischer, ich wünsche dir. Und was hat der gesagt? Er belustete halt ihre Augen, dann belustete sie einfach andere Türen. Ja, und dann war er ein bisschen pisst und meinte so, ja, wir mussten das zumachen, weil sonst die Leute, die rausgehen, in die Leute laufen, die reingehen. Und dann habe ich, oh Gott, das war ungelemmt, dann habe ich den Satz gesagt, Entschuldigung, dass sie wegen mir frustriert sind, aber ich habe einfach nur dieses Schild nicht richtig gelesen. Entschuldigung, dass sie wegen mir frustriert sind. Entschuldigung, dass sie wegen mir frustriert sind, weil er, und dann dachte ich, ich kann ihm somit jetzt ein Bein stellen, und dann war er, ja, nee, nee, alles gut. Und dann hat er mir noch, glaube ich, bestimmt drei Minuten lang erklärt, und es war interessant, was die Schwierigkeiten seines Jobs sind. Weil der war anscheinend dafür verantwortlich, dass diese Türen nicht mehr in Benutzung sind. Ich dachte auch gerade, du triffst jemanden, der nicht schuld an diesem Problem ist. Ja, genau. Er hat nie im Leben das Riesenplakat aufgehalten, wo draufsteht, da ist er auch gesagt. Aber stellst dich raus, er war tatsächlich genau der, der meinte, nein, wissen Sie, erst hatten wir vorne den Haupteingang offen, damit die Leute hier reingehen. Jetzt aber, der Messetag war schon zu Ende, jetzt wollen mehr Leute raus als rein.
Deswegen haben wir nur diesen einen Eingang für die Reinkommer gemacht und wollen jetzt aber nicht, dass alle Leute, die rausgehen, in diesen Eingang gehen und haben das, was früher die Eingänge war, sind jetzt die Ausgänge. Weil am Anfang des Tages muss natürlich der Eingang groß sein, am Ende des Tages muss der Ausgang groß sein. Wir haben hier Florentin Will. Was hast du für Spiele auf der Gamescom gespielt?
Und Florentin so, ja, also naja, Spiele eine Menge, aber was ich vor allem mitgenommen habe, ist, dass wie Menschenmassen sich bewegen in einem Kontext von Menschenmassen gemessen. Ja, und dann habe ich auch gesagt, ja, aber könnte man nicht dann dieses Schild auch ändern oder so, nee, das geht nicht, die sind ja fest installiert und so und dann, ja, sind wir eigentlich relativ versöhnlich gegangen, aber es war schön, wo wahrscheinlich beide Parteien dachten, was für ein Vollidiot, endeten wir mit, na die Welt ist komplizierter und schwieriger als man denkt und wir beide haben Fehler gemacht, wir beide haben aber auch große Probleme in unserem Leben, die nicht leicht zu lösen sind. Wundervoll, ich finde das eine wundervolle Geschichte, ja klar, wenn man ein bisschen sich auseinandersetzt mit dem Dunning-Krüger, irgendwann kommt dann raus, ah, okay, das war nur The Verge. Es ist nicht Dummheit, es ist einfach nur ein wahrscheinlich unlösbares Problem, Menschenmassen zu bewegen. Es ist viel komplexer als die Geschichte. Du wirst immer Leute irgendwie verprellen müssen, damit die Masse vernünftig durchkommt und ja. Ja, ich habe versucht immer, ich wollte dann auch Leute treffen da und habe dann die ganze Zeit versucht, dann Standort hin und her zu schicken, um zumindest grob zu wissen, welche Halle man gerade ist. Da kommt dann irgendwie, wir sind Halle 5. Ich weiß nicht. Vor allem ist Halle 5 auch nicht neben Halle 4 oder 3. Halle 6 ist neben Halle 9, wo ich mir dachte, weil die so ähnlich aussehen, die Zahlen, was ist die Logik hier? Was ist die Logik, ja, genau. Was soll das?
Ist ähnlich, vielleicht hat man früher, die ist einfach nur gedreht. Ja, vielleicht weil die Hallen genau umgedreht sind, man, keine Ahnung, furchtbar. Ja, genau, ich weiß auch nicht, die Halle sechsförmig, naja, naja, und dann habe ich so Standorte schicken wollen und dann hast du ja nicht so cool Empfang innerhalb dieses Messegeländes. und das GPS-Signal, glaube ich, orientiert sich immer so ein bisschen an deinem Handyempfang, Keine Ahnung, so habe ich mir das eingebaut. Das GPS-Signal ist dann auch geringer, was weiß ich. Jedenfalls steht dann immer bei WhatsApp zum Beispiel, auf wie viel Meter genau dieses Standortsecken gerade war. Oh ja. Und draußen war noch so, ich bin mit den Freunden vorher getroffen, wo verabredet, so ein Treffpunkt, und da war es auf 23 Meter genau. Und in der Halle dann wollte ich einen Standort schicken für einen Kumpel auf 1230 Meter genau, wo ich dachte, ja, okay, gut, also wir werden ihn nie wieder finden. Tschüss, wir haben verloren, Raphael ist jetzt verloren. Tschüss, Raphael ist jetzt Teil der Gamescom, Teil der Crew, Teil der Gamescom, Teil der Crew. Er wird so eingemauert in die Wand einfach, er ist Teil davon, er wird zur Gamescom.
Oder er kriegt so ein Mario-Kostüm drüber, ich weiß nicht.
Ich hätte ja auch mal Bock auf Cosplay, das ist ja auch auf der Gamescom.
Weil du nicht erkannt werden willst.
Ja, ich würde mehr erkannt werden gerne, sozusagen, dass ich dann noch ein cooles Kostüm habe.
Und ich glaube, du wirst nirgendwo so wenig komisch angeschaut wie auf der Gamescom.
Du kannst aussehen, wie du willst, du kannst tragen, was du willst. Nichts, nichts verwundert dich auf der Gamescom. Aber das ist so cool an Köln. Alles ist da irgendwie vertreten. In Köln gibt es so viele Daten, wo das der Fall ist. Sei es Karneval, sei es CSD, sei es Gamescom. Ist wundervoll, ich liebe das. Allein diese ganzen Anime-Ereignisse, auch wieder Japan-Tag und Düsseldorf, auch wenn ich normal in der Innenstadt jemand mit Anime-Manga-Verkleidung sehe, null. Ich bemerke das nicht mal. Das ist einfach immer irgendwas. Einzigartig, also was die Masse an dieser, ich glaube es kommt auch damals Handel statt, sehr viele fremde Menschen waren eh immer schon da, alle aus verschiedenen Backgrounds, verschiedenen Berufen, verschiedenen Interessen, Nischeninteressen, alle liefen immer selbstbewusst hier mit Basically Cosplay durch die Gegend und waren damit fein.
Ich mag das sehr.
Ich finde das auch cool, aber ich kenne fast keine von diesen Figuren so.
Also ich bin da null irgendwie, obwohl ich ja Gamer bin oder so, aber ich glaube, ich spiele nicht die, was gerade so diese Cosplay-Leute kommen, aber irgendwann, ich dachte mir, ich mache dann Cosplay so als Mo von den Simpsons oder so und dann alle so so, einfach, du bist so alt und staubig und so
und niemand wird sagen, alter Mo,
geil, so dann Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo,
Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo, Mo,
Mo, einfach niemand.
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, wenn man Gamer ist,
spielt man ja auch nicht alle Spiele.
Richtig. Man spielt, man hat Interessen.
So in dieser sehr aufgespitterten,
diversen Welt. Und dann kommst du auf diese
Messe und dann war auch einer bei uns der Gamer und dann haben wir ihn immer gefragt, wer ist das, wer ist das, wer ist das, wo das Gesicht ein Baum ist und der Unterteil einem. Kein unmöglich, alle Franchises kennen, es gibt zu viel. Und dann war aber die Situation, ah und wer ist der mit dem Gesicht, mit der Kettensäge und er wusste, ach so, dass der aus dem Anime von, und der Rot hatte genau eine Antwort drauf gehabt, das war wiederum ganz cool. Ich hatte viel Spaß da an der Messe. Ich fand das cool. Ich auch und ich finde das auch immer cool. Ich weiß nicht, ob alle Cosplayer oder Kostümierten das sind, aber manche sind auch so ein bisschen in Character. Also dann gerade so Stormtrooper finde ich immer cool. Immer dann so, ja, wir sind auf der Suche nach Rebellen und so, ich glaube da hinten und so. Kann man immer irgendwie so interagieren, finde ich immer cool, weil die oft in Characters sind, aber musst du natürlich auch das Franchise kennen, ansonsten ist so ein bisschen lost. Bist du völlig lost. Aber ich mag das, wo wir gerade dabei sind, dass auf dem Boden noch Markierungen da sind aus dem Relikt einer anderen Zeit. Ich finde das total toll, dass manche Dinge sehr klar besprochen sind. Es ist, glaube ich, ich glaube, du magst Zebrastreifen genauso sehr wie ich. Ja. Wo so sehr klar ist, was hier die, es ist irgendwie so ein Raum, der nur durch grosse Balken plötzlich ganz klar sagt, wer hat hier die Hosen an, wer hat hier den Vorteil. Und die Gesellschaft hat sich komplett darauf geeinigt. Es reicht nur eine kleine Verbindung am Boden und plötzlich der Fußgänger ist der King oder Queen. Fußgänger läuft über die Strasse, Audis haben anzuhalten. Aber es bricht auch, und ich liebe das sehr, und ich als Autofahrer bin ich super respektvoll, als Fußgänger bin ich super, ich nehme das so richtig an mich, die Rolle des, ich laufe einfach drüber, weil ich denke mir, ich teile wie Moses, teile ich das mehr. Ja, absolut, wobei ich mir als Autofahrer manchmal mschen würde, dass die Leute klarer signalisieren, ob sie den Zebrastreifen jetzt benutzen oder nicht. Weil es gibt oft die, die dann so entweder die Straße entlanglaufen und dann so schlagartig einkurven. Das bin ich. Auch teilweise ohne zu gucken. Das mache ich nämlich. Wo du immer denkst, ich muss jetzt neben dir langsam herfahren, weil ich nicht weiß, ob du einblickst. Da würde ich mir wünschen, kurzer Blick, Augenkontakt, kurzes Zebrastreifensymbol mit den Händen, kurze Geste, die alle verstehen. Das Zebrastreifensymbol mit den Händen? Ja, kloppe die klopp, die Hufe. Die Hufe. Na, wenn du mit den Händen so wie so die Zebra Hufe, kloppe die klopp. Warum nicht so Striche für Zebra? Ne, das ist so kurze Pause bitte. Ich brauche kurz fünf Minuten, ich brauche kurz so ein langes Sandwich. Ah, okay. Bis hierhin und nicht weiter. Du zeigst die Pause an, ich brauche eine Pause, die so lang ist wie ein Sandwich, das so lang ist, bis ich es esse. Ja, das ist ja auch genial, das ist genial, wenn man Flüge, Flugzeuge einweist, diese Lotsen, die unten stehen, die ja dann diese Fackeln haben, die dann so langsam zusammengehen, je nachdem, wie viel Platz noch ist. Super. Und dann ist Platz vorbei und dann raus. Genial. Das ist genial. Ja, aber ich mag Zebrastreifen sehr, aber es ist natürlich schon dann blöd, wenn du einen Fahrradfahrer auf dem Zebrastreifen hast. Oder, also sowohl auf dem Zebrastreifen, weil es sind Fussgänger überweg. Und das ist die Frage, lässt du als Autofahrer musst du Fahrräder rein? Umfahren, direkt umfahren. Direkt umfahren, gar keine Gnade. Gar keine Gnade. Ich bin bei langsam anfahren, bin ich gerade. Ah, okay. Ach so, langsam so anstupsen. Ja, so, was soll das gerade?, wenn man die Grenzen ausloten. Wer hat hier eigentlich recht gerade?
Oh, ich würde gewinnen als Auto.
Ich habe ja schon mal bemängelt,
dass man als Auto wenig Kommunikation hat.
Du hast nur die Hupe und die Lichthupe, aber ausserhalb der Hupe
gibt es wenig. Ich war zum Beispiel auf der Autobahn
und auf der rechten Seite
fuhr vor mir ein Auto,
das links geblinkt hat.
Die ganze Zeit. Für mich klare Situation,
oh, der will die Spur wechseln, ich halte Abstand.
Halte also Abstand, halte mich
hinter dem Auto, wechsle die Spur nicht.
Und obwohl Platz
ist, und denke mir, okay, vielleicht bin ich zu nah,
nehme noch mehr Abstand, wechsle die
Spur nicht, wird niemals gewechselt
werden. Bis ich irgendwann gemerkt habe, der
will wahrscheinlich die Spur nicht
wechseln, er blinkt einfach nur,
checkt vielleicht nicht, dass er blinkt.
Und jetzt war wieder so diese Situation,
genau die gleiche Situation,
Bis zum nächsten Mal. will wahrscheinlich die Spur nicht wechseln, er blinkt einfach nur, checkt vielleicht nicht, dass er blinkt. Und jetzt war wieder so die Situation, genau die gleiche Situation wie beim Inder, wo ich mir dachte, dem haben schon hunderte Leute gesagt, dass der blinkt. Ich sag dem, sie blinken, ja, ich weiß. Ja, warum ändern sie es nicht? Und dann dachte ich mir, soll ich das sagen? Und dann dachte ich mir, wie sage ich das jetzt? Weil es war Autobahn, 120, fahre ich neben den und dann bin ich ja links und er ist rechts von mir. Also wie gut sieht er mich? Muss ich jetzt so unten? Wie komme ich jetzt genau mit der Hand? Wie genau soll das funktionieren? Dann dachte ich mir so von über, also mit der linken Hand übers Dach. Da fährst du so schnell auf der Autobahn. Übers Dach. Und deine Hand so. Arm verloren einfach direkt. Und ich habe es, muss ich zugeben, halb gar versucht mit meinem Blinksymbol. Du sagst ja immer, dass man so blinkt. Deins ist wie? Ich mache so. Laber, laber, laber. Ich mache die Labergeste, du machst diese Sonnenstrahlgeste. Ich mache nur Laber, Laber, Laber, habe ihm Laber, Laber, Laber gegeben, hat nicht mal hingeguckt, keine Chance. Weil er war auch erhöht, es war wie so ein VW-Bus erhöht und ich war ja zu weit weg. Und das heißt, der Winkel war ganz furchtbar, aber das natürlich auch, wenn man da einfach so eine Klappe am Auto hätte, wo man innen mit einer Kreidetafel was schreibt und dann fährt man vor das andere Auto und klappt die so auf seitlich, so dass der andere sie jetzt lesen kann, also wie so eine Art Tür, dass man innen an die Tür eine Kreidetafel macht und da schreibt Blinker, Ausrufezeichen, dann fahre ich vorhin und mache die Tür auf, ist natürlich schwer mit dem Blinker. Blinker, Ausrufezeichen ist ja genau da, sie haben den linken Blinker angelassen. Na ja gut, wenn ich ihn auf Blinker hinweist, dann merke ich, dann checkt er schon was los, oder? Nach der Logik kannst du auch das. Ich meine nur, hinten kam die Polizei ja manchmal, die haben ja dieses bitte Folgending. Warum hat sowas nicht jeder? Das wäre so geil. Ist es ein rechtliches Ding, oder kann man theoretisch, können alle hinten dieses LED-Band machen und dann, okay, Fahrer muss es ja nicht machen, aber der Beifahrer, Beifahrerin kann ja reinschreiben, sie haben so ein schönes Lächeln oder so.
Darf man so ein iPad oder so ein Monitor hinten an seine Scheibe von innen dran kleben, so dass man es von außen lesen kann? Genau, das finde ich ja super geil. Ich fände das echt nützlich, weil es ist ja wirklich oft, ihr Blinker ist an, sie fahren zu langsam, sie haben mich geschnitten, bitte blinken, wenn sie abbiegen, würde ich gerne einfach machen. Ich glaube, deswegen sind auch diese Autos. Bewerten sie diesen Fahrer, ist häufig auch. Ja, also ich glaube, deswegen sind ja auch diese Autosticker, Baby on Board oder sowas, oder für wen man gewählt hat, deswegen muss man diese dummen Sticker wählen, weil man keine anderen Möglichkeiten hat. In Deutschland hast du das nicht, für wen du gewählt hast.
Das ist auch so, das ist so American.
Scholz 2020.
Honk if you love Scholz.
Gestern Auto gesehen von Gaffel Wies, deutsches, kölsches Bier, Kölsch halt. Und da stand hinten drauf, hupen Sie, wenn Sie es probieren wollen. Und das habe ich nicht verstanden. Entweder man ... Nein, das funktioniert nicht. Was passiert dann? Wenn ich den bei 180 auf der Autobahn sehe, hinter dem fahre, viel zu eng, dass ich es lesen kann. Viel zurant, schnell, hupe, ja. Und hupe, was löse ich dann aus für einen Prozess, in dem Gaffel weiss, wie ist das Auto. Und dann kommt hinten, bitte folgen, fährt rechts, fährt rechts ran und dann kriegt sie ein Glas. Oder dann wird das Auto so, da wird dann die Folie draussen abgemacht und darunter ist ein Polizeiauto. Und die sagen, sie sind zu dicht aufgefahren. Und sie haben gehupt, sie dürfen nicht hupt. Ich habe auf dem Autostand, tja, wir haben sie jetzt. Sie wurden reingelegt, sie wurden rechtlich reingelegt. Ja, das Bier existiert überhaupt nicht. Es ist einfach eine komplette Undercover-Operation. Es gibt kein Gaffelwies, kein Wort. Gaffel, soll es überhaupt sein? Ich habe oft Schwierigkeiten mit Gaffel. Das ist ja ein Wort, das man relativ häufig liest, aber ich habe immer in meinem Kopf, weil es gibt ja diese Frakturschrift, wo das S so aussieht wie ein F. Gassel. Und wo ich immer bei Gassel, Gaffel bin und deswegen habe ich es auch noch nie probiert. Deswegen müssen die vielleicht mit ihr so verzweifelten Aktionen wie, stören Sie den Verkehr, um eine kleine Kostprobe zu bekommen oder erzeugen Sie eine möglicherweise riskante Verkehrssituation
Lassen Sie den Motor auffäulen, driften Sie,
wenn Sie es probieren wollen.
Ein Donut, ein Glas.
Das ist das Angebot.
Stellen Sie mir die Vorfahrt, um zu probieren.
Und der Fahrer weiß nicht, was hinten draufsteht.
Das ist Kick-Me-Zeichen.
Er weiß nicht, was...
Und stimm mal, wo du weißt, hupen Sie, wenn Sie es probieren wollen
und du weißt nicht... Genau, jemand klebt dir das hinten drauf. Lennart, was... Und für dennoch, wo du weißt, hupen sie, wenn sie es probieren wollen, und du weißt nicht...
Genau, jemand klebt dir das hinten drauf.
Lennart, Lennart, Lennart,
was denn? Kannst du ganz kurz, ich weiss, du bist
der Praktikant und es ist der erste Tag eigentlich, aber kannst du dir ganz kurz
das Auto nehmen und jetzt so kurz
zu meiner Frau fahren hier für das
und gibst dir einfach hier den Einkauf aus dem Bewerb.
Okay, mache ich, alles klar, gut. Und dann steigt
Lennart ins Auto, in den
Gaffelwies, hupen sie, wenn sie was probieren wollen. Hochrotter Kopf von allen Seiten. Was ist denn, was ist denn, ist das Licht aus, was ist los, blinkig? Ich mag Köln nicht, Köln, alle rufen mich an, das ist schrecklich, blinkig, ich weiss nicht, was los ist. Lennart. Klar, ich habe noch nie gehupt in meinem Leben, nie. Ich weiss, du bist ein, du hupst gerne und viel und hast mich auch schon mehrfach angehupt, aber würde würde ich nicht machen. Ich glaube, ich finde, es bräuchte noch so ein anderes Geräusch, das so eher freundlich klingt, eher wie so ein Fahrradklingeln oder so, dass es nicht so ein, sondern eher so ein, was schönes klärendes Hafiges oder sowas. Einfach wo man so einen kleinen Impuls so, hallo, ich bin auch noch hier im Verkehr. Irgendein Kaiser hatte, so ein deutscher Kaiser hatte dann so ein frühes erstes Auto und da hatte er in seine Hupe war irgendwie so ein kleiner Little Funny Tune von irgendeiner Oper. Ach was. Ach guck mal. So, aber sowas und ich habe das mir vorgesummt und vorgestellt, ich habe mich kaputt gelacht, weil das so ganz peinlich. Aber wie geht das? Hat er dann so eine Reihe von Hupen, die er dann so, muss er dann selber spielen, wie so ein kleiner. Was? Was denn? Was denn? Was denn? So, hinter dir ist ein Kaiser und du sitzt da in deinem Fiat Punto und sagst, was denn? Was denn? Gar nichts zu sagen. Ist noch nicht fertig.
Das dauert 18 Minuten.
Vor allem in der Zeit, wo es in der ganzen Stadt drei Autos gab.
Ich glaube, damals waren Autofahrer nicht so selbstbewusst. So, mit der Fahrer vorne, hier, zack, hinten raus. Sondern die waren einfach so, hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht, hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht, hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht. Unter mir explodiert gerade Treibstoff, hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht, hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht. Dieses Auto wird mit Kohle betrieben, or so. Aber ja, wahrscheinlich war es, das fällt mir jetzt dann auch auf,
wahrscheinlich war es keine Hupe im Achtung, Achtung Sinne,
sondern im Sinne von Hier kommt der Kaiser bei Paraden oder so.
Ach so, das kann auch so.
Und das wäre dann eigentlich los.
Oder du hast halt als Kaiser immer so einen Adjutanten mit einer Trompete neben dir,
der immer deinen Song spielt, wenn du in den Raum kommst.
Ich würde gerne einen Song.
Deinen eigenen Song für dich allein, so dein Theme, Stephans Theme. Ja, früher Beethoven hat irgendwie zum Namenstag von auch irgendeinem, was auch immer, in der Hoheit so einen Song geschrieben für den Namenstag. Aber dafür benutzt er nicht sein bestes Material, oder? Habe ich auch gedacht. Der Namenstag. Wo ich mir dachte so, du machst doch nicht jetzt als Namenstag,
ein Lied, das nie wieder jemand hört, machst du da jetzt nicht dein gutes Zeug, das B-Material.
Freundin von dir lehrt dich ein zum Geburtstag.
Dann besorgst du ein Geschenk.
Sie feiert einfach mal so.
Sie hat einen Bachelor gemacht.
Feiert einen Bachelor.
Dann schenkst du ihr nicht dein bestes Geschenk oder was Teures, sondern...
So Platz drei, vier auf der Liste. Ja, oder bringst du einen Wein mit oder so eine Gaffelwies. Oder eine Popcornmaschine oder so was. Bringst du einen Gaffelwies, besorgst du noch schnell, weil du hupen durch die Straße fährst und hoffst, wenn irgendwer wird. Aber genau. Da kriegst du an jeder Ecke quasi so ein Brücklafen. Und dann nicht, Stefan feiert seinen Namenstag. Was schenkst du mit? Da schenkst du auch nichts Gutes. Nee. Genau. Ich glaube, ich würde dir ein Rubbel los schenken oder so. Geiles Geschenk. Und dann sau wütend sein, wenn du gewinnst. Und den ganzen Abend bin ich richtig... Sag mal, das kann nicht sein. Das sind 10.000 Euro! Fluentine, vielen Dank! Äh, ach so. Vielen Dank, das ist das beste Geschenk. Ich passe, guck 10.000 Euro, ist der Wahnsinn! Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Fluentine! Ich habe es ja gekauft. Vielen Dank, das ist das beste Geschenk, ich passe, guck 10.000 Euro, ist der Wahnsinn. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Flurinzien. Weil ich hab's ja gekauft. Vielen Dank, ey, zum Namenstag hast du mir jetzt quasi 10.000 Euro geschenkt. Ey, das hau ich alles auf den Kopf für Pferdesperma. Vielleicht können wir es irgendwie teilen oder so, wäre vielleicht ganz cool. Mega, vielen Dank fürs Geschenk. Wenn wir es vielleicht für die ganze Party teilen oder so, weil ich sehr gekauft habe, können wir vielleicht... Das ist wie ein Sketch, wie so ein I-Think-You-Shit-Leaf-Sketch eigentlich. Eigentlich so ein... Pferdesperma? Ich lege das alles an. Wir kaufen mit 10.000 Kaffee, 3 Liter, was sind das? Was sind das? Hat jemand den Kurs? Stop, stop, stop, stop, mach die Musik aus. Hat jemand kurz den Kurs? Ja, Markus hat immer den Kurs. Das sind so dreieinhalb Liter aktuell. Dreieinhalb Liter gutes Pferdesperma. Okay, ist das mehr Bitcoins? Das sind Bitcoins 0,01 Bitcoin. Okay, Pferdesperma das. PS, Pferdesperma. PS, rein da. Schön die Buddel abzapfen. Aber es ist wertvoll, es ist wirklich wertvoll. Ich glaube auch. Also wenn es von einem guten Pferd ist, dann kannst du da richtig Geld verdienen.
Aber auch da die Frage, woher weisst du, ob es ein gutes Pferd ist? Oder wurde ich mal wieder reingelegt? Wird das gefälscht? Meinst du, da gibt es auch, also das ist ja wirklich so in Zucht und ich finde es ja ganz spannend, das Thema Taubenzucht finde ich zum Beispiel ganz interessant, weil es gibt Sporttaubenzüchter, die natürlich die beste Taube haben wollen. Und das ist richtig abgefahren, weil die packen, also sagen wir mal, tausend Leute machen mit, dann packen die alle tausend Tauben in den Lastwagen, fahren mit dem Lastwagen irgendwo hin, machen den auf und die Tauben fliegen alle wieder einzeln zu Hause zu ihren Heimatorten und dann wird gestoppt, wann die heimkommen. Welcher SDZ gewonnen hat? Und wer als erstes kommt. Also welcher SDZ gewonnen hat?
Sportarm-Sichter.
Welcher SDZ hat dann gewonnen?
Und da ist natürlich auch sehr wichtig, weil die leben nicht lange, da brauchst du
natürlich auch gute Zuchtauben. Die Thees.
Und da gibt es aber auch hin und wieder mal Dopingfälle.
Was kriegen die dann?
Ähm,
ein Mass? Ich weiss es nicht.
Wie genau man die dopt.
Aber keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall gibt es dann halt welche, die offensichtlich zu krass sind und die werden dann gegessen. Von den Inspekteuren, die kommen dann dahin und sagen so, komm mal, schauen Sie mal an, der hat riesen Augenringe, der Täuberich hier. Gucken Sie sich mal an, der zittert am ganzen Leib. Sind Drogen Dopingmittel fürs Leben. Naja. Stefan. Wenn man mit Alkohol besser sozial ist. Da haben wir doch schon drüber geredet. Das müssen wir doch jetzt hier nicht im Podcast noch mal. Ich weiss, da gab es diese Intervention zu Hause, wo alle waren. Donny, Herm, Tommy, Jan, Olli, Hazel, Ariana, Laura, alle Podcaster, Chris und Julia, Fakan, Christian, alle waren da, Pete, Marc, Sophie, Yoko, Joe, alle waren da.
Und Malcolm.
Alle waren da und wir haben darüber gesprochen.
Michelle.
Das.
Aber welche?
Ja, Michelle war da, Marc, Marc hatten wir schon gerade schon gesagt.
Barack.
Ja, einer der Baracks, die wir mögen und lieben, für das, was er ist. Ja, einer der Baracks, die wir mögen und lieben.
Für das, was er ist.
Ja.
Und habt ihr gesagt, nee, Stefan, Drogen
sind keine Dopingmittel fürs Leben.
Ich würde sagen, Drogen sind Cheatcode
fürs Leben. Die machen es leichter,
aber zu einem harten Preis.
Was ist der Preis?
Na gut, Gesundheit.
Ja, tatsächlich, ich habe jetzt auch wieder
die neue Netflix-Serie Painkiller gesehen.
Ist ja tatsächlich ein Thema, da geht es um
die Opiat-Krise
in den USA, Oxycontin,
Produpharma.
Gibt es ja relativ
ich sag, ich wollte es überdecken.
Ja, mit dem gleichen
Geräusch. Dankeschön. Das machst du immer in der Öffentlichkeit. Ich weiß, du willst mir helfen, wenn ich im Restaurant niesen muss, Schatz, aber du musst ja nicht genau das gleiche Geräusch machen. Ich will, dass die Leute denken, dass ich niese, nicht du. Es führt dazu, dass wir mit verstärkter Lautstärke beide durch den Laden blären. Der gesamte Laden. Oder erschrecken sich. Weil beide. Aber du kündigst es immer so weit an, du bist so leicht zu treffen, wenn du so. Du bist, weißt du, das ist so verführerisch, weil dein Timing so offensichtlich ist. Vielleicht machst du eher so aus dem Nichts heraus, so links, rechts. Ja, ja, ist rechts, das würde ich antäuschen. Naja, ich wollte nur sagen, es gibt zwei Serien über die Opiatkrise, es gibt einmal Painkiller und es gibt Dope Sick. Zwei unterschiedliche Streaming-Dienste haben eine Serie zu dem gleichen historischen Ereignis. Ist das jetzt sowas wie der neue Trojanische Krieg? So, das war es für die heutige Folge. Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche. Wünsche ich euch auch. Macht's gut, kommt wieder nach Hause und fahrt vorsichtig. Liebe Grüße, Florentin und Steffi.
Florentin und Stefan, der wichtigste Beifahrer ist die Gesundheit.
Macht's gut, ciao.